hey guys it's Justine hi I'm not Justine
no you're not this is Austin and I'm so
excited because today we're doing a fun
little collab so we're going to be
unboxing two different laptops so first
we're gonna unbox mine and then we're
gonna be heading over to your channel
and unboxing another one I've seen that
this box is already open okay I couldn't
wait I had to just see what was inside
of it I just wanted to take a little
peek but I didn't actually unbox the
laptop itself okay so this is the new
Asus VivoBook S14 Asus has this really
interesting thing on their laptop
keyboards they have an antibacterial
guard and obviously I think we all know
that keyboards are pretty disgusting
after a while especially if you're
traveling and using them so consistently
so I'm excited to check that out I'll
leave the testing to you and I'll just
use the laptop well I think we're
basically going to be testing out the
laptop because I feel like to be able to
actually test out the the antibacterial
would have to get a lab and do all of
this kind of stuff I just trust that
they did the research I'm excited for
what's coming after our unboxing okay
look let's spoil it let's not spoil it
okay my impending Victory or anything
we're gonna be doing a little laptop
challenge of doing a bunch of random
tasks and we're gonna see who wins now
we're going to be using both of our
different laptops so we've unboxed here
so after this video make sure you go
check out Austin's to see who wins
because we're not going to tell you who
wins in either of these videos you're
gonna have to go and tally it up I got a
little question for you yeah um what do
you have two things in your box I don't
know I didn't open it yet well you kind
of opened it well I just opened a peek I
just wanted to make sure the laptop was
in there
not an empty box you never know I once
got a phone delivered and there was
nothing inside of it so just wanted to
be sure this is so exciting I'm on your
set I know like this is so cool you can
even if you want you can talk to the top
camera I'm not a big fan of that yeah
great like we've got a little yeah top
down action here I already opened this
but I did bring some knives for the
unboxing do we want to bring some oh
yeah yes I see some knives here yep here
we go oh here we go do you want to pick
which one you like go ahead pick which
one you want be great the camera
yeah yeah
we're talking camera apparently okay all
right here we go okay so I'm gonna need
some assistance okay okay ready okay
wow look at this wow the world
I feel loud a laptop pouch what it's a
backpack
oh that's what you're gonna need okay
what are treats okay I'm gonna open this
first
wait does this actually come with this
they just said it to you because they
like you
I mean I think this comes with it
um we didn't get a backpack but you got
a monitor oh yeah yeah
so Matt Fisher I'm not gonna I love
laptop bags so this is actually look at
this oh look at that
one little space here
we've got another space here this is
actually really nice to have included I
know this is very nice okay okay
interesting we'll set that aside of the
world yet I think we can wow it now okay
are you ready I am ready I'm about to be
wild though oh actually wait I I think I
have a spoiler for this let's just do
really cool boxes when it opens up it
should present the laptop
yeah it does look at that oh
plus the environment Go Green Save Green
it's actually that's a good slogan I
like that that is pretty great
wow
thank you
oh oh what is this like a little like a
size too explore the possibilities
that's actually built into the laptop
look at this look at that Zoom to really
emphasize
so we've got 100 DCI P3 one thousand to
one contrast ratio for HDR and low blue
light with Eye Care flicker free low
blue light I know that's best to use
blue light filters but I think I spent
too much time around color stuff that I
don't anytime I turn that on and the the
screen goes warm to save your eyes I'm
like that's not cool accurate that's not
what the bluest wants to look like I do
the same thing so if I'm like editing or
something like that like I definitely
turn it off but if I'm doing just like
email like it is so much better you
actually see you actually use it oh I
definitely switch it which does make a
huge difference I want color accuracy
100 of the time in my life I only want
it when I'm editing oh look at this
anti-bacterial guard does it say anyone
oh it's Pantone validated oh actually
that's pretty neat that is great I think
this red Escape key actually you know
what this little entrance oh yeah it's
got a little bit of texture so you know
I'll say like I feel like Asus make
obviously lost and lots of laptops they
have a wide variety up and down the the
product range I really like the
aesthetic of this I like the black sort
of finish where it's kind of got a
little bit of sort of texture to it you
also have what seems to be a little bit
like you said the splash of color oh
this is my favorite lay flat henge yes
so it's interesting like this feels like
it is a little bit more of a
Pro feature set on the laptop right
because obviously it's 14 inch it's
super thin super light but you've got
the OLED display you've got the
antibacterial finish but you also have a
bunch of stuff like the ego
certification with the core i7 yeah and
I also like that it has this finish but
like it's not impacting like the
keyboard at all like it just looks
normal it types normal and this is
something that they have done in a
variety of their laptops too and I
didn't even know it this is so cool so
that's I think actually how this whole
project kind of came up because the
suits were talking about like oh you
know we do this antibacterial coating
I'm gonna make sure because you
obviously your laptops can get dirty and
gross and it makes a lot of sense and I
had never even thought about it like I
know like for my phone I'll put in one
of those like little UV Santos all the
time good luck trying to fit your laptop
in there yeah no you can't do that so it
does have the webcam Shield so you can
just cover it up which is nice it's
fully built in so definitely shout out
to that AI noise cancellation
two Thunderbolt four you got a USB a on
the side nice nice yeah this is actually
pretty cool because I'm so used to using
a large laptop yeah and like having
something that is so small portable and
Compact and yet still powerful enough to
be able to get everything done that you
need yeah like maybe we will test out
some gaming in our competition I can't
believe we already had a laptop and a
backpack actually that is really nice
I'm surprised I don't think I've ever
seen a laptop come with a backup here we
are there you go we've got a oh it's
USBC that's nice 90 watt charger so
what's nice about it is it does charge
via USBC so you've got those two
lightning ports so obviously you can use
the charger that comes in the box or
most USBC monitors or whatever will also
be able to power your laptop and help
you to charge at the same time I like
how small this is like it's a nice sort
of fit but also it's not like so crazy
thing where you can see they've clearly
got not that we're going to take this
apart for the video or anything I would
never do that but you can see they've
clearly thought about the cooling you
see actually one of the large fans right
right in there it also feels just nice
just just feel that in your hand like it
just it feels like solid right it's
pretty light too considering oh let's
take this off oh good job assist it is
time to start the competition is that
where the dramatic music comes in maybe
we'll see if I can find a good track or
not
the first Challenge on my channel is
going to be a typing test now on yours
we're going to be doing the A to Z
you're having shamelessly standing for
Marquez but it's really hard I'm excited
to try it out so right now we're just
gonna do this General typing test and
see who gets a better score so we're
just gonna go one shot fastest but
there's also accuracy how are we gonna
play with accuracy just whatever well we
have our judge over here yeah no my time
to shine
so what do you think we're gonna average
out words per minute with accuracy okay
okay I mean like I can I just declare
Justine the winner for this I make a lot
of mistakes though oh yeah how fast do
you as a typer I don't know a typist I
don't know a typing person I'm okay I'm
I'm okay should I take off all my
jewelry because now my arms feel heavy
no you're not just like limber it's like
it's like using weight so like you want
to practice with all the jewelry on and
then take it off when you do that we got
one shot here yeah there's no do-over
there's no try over there's no do you
guys want one practice round no no good
I gotta take this off though I got the
power of my vivobooks amazing trackpad
keyboard and ergonomic combination well
that is great but unfortunately a
trackpad does not do a whole lot in the
typing test that is also true I'm just
looking at how big my trackpad is and it
makes me feel encouraged well are you
ready I am okay okay okay that's the
countdown all right we're gonna go three
two wait do we go on one yeah yeah good
question three two one go yeah
I will give you three two one go okay
perfect okay okay ready
three two one go okay well immediately
mess up the first one oh I messed up
see a lot of red don't think you're
supposed to have red oh I'm choking
right now this is not good
I gotta get back in my rhythm oh this is
look
[Music]
you're already done are you wait I'm
done are we do we have the same amount
of letters and words
I'm confused
wait yeah we do have the same how did
because I'm not that fast
you're 180 words per minute and I messed
up a bunch
108. like I wasn't even trying
like I'm not no joke I was like typing
slow because I didn't want to mess up
too many times I thought I was like it
was like slow I didn't I honestly like
when I looked over and you haven't you
worked hard times
okay that was a horrible run by me but
my like average in this test is like
high 80s low 90s so even my best is not
108. I'm actually surprised I didn't
know I don't I'm curious how the
accuracy worked for this because I saw
you get a lot wrong so you can get it
wrong but if you backspace down fix it
it doesn't count oh but it obviously
counts against your time you only lose
accuracy if you hit enter and you move
on or you hit space and you move on well
Justine had a 98 accuracy I'm 97. I only
had one word wrong
I mean you had I got my first word wrong
ironically the word first but wow I mean
is there anything to judge here like you
just uh I will give you that I wonder
who won I don't know I I'm shook I can't
believe you're that fast I mean I didn't
think that I yeah and I didn't really
try which I'm oh I feel bad about
thanks just casually just wrecking him
wow just ruined that man's whole career
who knows what's gonna happen on your
channel maybe we know I think we know we
don't know we don't know we do so this
next challenge I'm pretty excited about
we're gonna be using this really
high-end performance
app called Microsoft Page look here's
the thing right we to express our
creativity using the best tools
available sure some might use Photoshop
or
3D rendering you know what though I
learned how to use Ms paint when I was
it was my childhood yeah I was going to
say I think it was like 10 when I
started using Ms paint yeah and uh why
mess with the best so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna make thumbnails now
how do we want to do this do you want to
make a thumbnail for me do you want to
make a thumbnail for yourself for your
video should we just have Matt decide
who made the better thumbnail yeah yeah
and then those would get stuck with the
worst ones what was last time you used
Ms paint it's been a while I mean I
sometimes use it whenever I do like
screenshots and stuff like that yeah
sometimes I'll just paste it in save it
you know I don't think I've opened up Ms
paint since I was running like this
stuff a little bit a little bit but you
know what I'm looking at it it's here
Windows 11 and it looks beautiful and I
think I've got every tool I could
possibly imagine I got my paint bucket I
got my pencil and my Eraser and some
colors eyedropper too important
eyedropper I can eyeball magnifying
glass oh we're set okay all right
um so I'm gonna give you guys three
minutes okay to do this
and at the end of that three minutes you
better have masterpieces oh
you guys doing what are you Woody shoes
give me as soon as this is cheating you
need Justine the better version of paint
okay look at you and click your about
I don't have anything down at the bottom
about oh okay I'm on paint 11.2 you're
on paint 10.2
I don't have the paint update no uh I
feel like we have to play it as it lies
guys like this literally looks like what
I use at the beginning like you got like
look at this this is actually kind of
interesting I have a relic here I guess
give us a countdown three minutes yeah
three minutes three two one go
okay I'm already off to a good start so
I'm gonna just oh okay no no no don't do
that don't do that where am I missing
something so I have a very specific idea
in mind okay and my Creative Vision is
going to execute this to the fullest
like I actually went to school to be a
graphic designer so I don't know if
that's like a good time to talk about it
uh so here's the thing I used to do a
lot pixel art and uh in pain like I
would mess with like Sprites and whatnot
oh look I've got a multi-touch trackpad
for paint whoa okay okay all right this
is good I like this uh I'm feeling good
I'm feeling good I'm feeling great I'm
feeling snazzy and spectacular I am not
doing well
okay I gotta cast my mind back
Windows XP Bliss background
uh is that what you're doing yes
everyone can tell trying to make a pink
square and it's not working well you
have one minute to make it you're still
working on your image
everyone's gonna be so nostalgic for
window
S I feel very confident oh oh I've got
an idea I've got an idea I've got an
idea I don't have a time Matt how much
time do we have oh 10 seconds
wow I'm making a big broccoli I'm making
a big broccoli broccoli
finish my painting I don't know I mean
this took me three minutes I'm not proud
at all look at that shapes you got a a
lightning bolt
s I've got Windows XP Bliss that's
pretty close right yeah I mean that's
that's it's nice I didn't finish my tree
though I was trying to I'll be the judge
of that okay I don't want you to see our
artwork hmm oh yeah look I almost you
gave me you can give me a 10 second
warning I wasn't ready if you would take
10 seconds I would have stopped I was in
the middle and you said oh by the way
you're done I'm just saying that seems
unfair
so what I like about justines is it has
Thunderbolt
showing off the features that this guy
has oh no
um here's a here's a comparison yeah
where's the tree what is the trees
that's the tree because it's the
environment you should have done the
windows 11 Bloom yeah it's I like this
includes features of the laptops yours
didn't and I just wanted to show that I
loved it so much
but you didn't complete your thought
yours does look like a Valentine's that
you if you're in like kindergarten will
you be my valentine
but like the one that you give to like
that you had to give out to like yeah
not like your favorite friend yeah the
kid you like okay I gotta I gotta doc
Austin point for adding to a masterpiece
you don't get the Mona Lisa and then
give her I don't know mustache I'm like
yeah or a hat well but you know I'm just
I don't know I gotta I gotta I mean
there's not a lot to go on here I gotta
go with cleaner heart cleaner lightning
bolts and cleaner uh thought bubbles
those clouds you guys are those are
shapes that are preset buttons right I
free handed this there's nothing about
being a better freehander of making a
better image I'm an artiste
apparently not I'm a creative
I'm a innovator entrepreneur and also
now a loser
oh
for the record it's not a now a loser
thing it's just I didn't mean it I'm
sorry maybe you'll do better on your
channel thanks is this my channel is my
channel you could maybe redeem yourself
thanks
I feel attacked and judged and I don't
think
so right now we're going to be doing a
TSA challenge I have done this maneuver
many times in the airport where I'm
either trying to make a thumbnail I'm
trying to do something on my computer
and I'm like scooting around you know
like in the airport and I said this
would be very fitting because the
airport's kind of dirty and grimy and
this is the antibacterial guard so I
know that we're safe and we're protected
antibacterial guards help when I
inevitably drop my laptop on the ground
because I'm trying to push this suitcase
too hard let's hope that doesn't happen
so it's gonna happen what we're gonna do
is we're gonna be cruising around these
markers here that were for the table
that has been removed and what are we
going to make presentation about uh I'll
figure it out as I go along okay okay
cool don't want to give you too much of
it okay all right all right I'm ready so
we just got to do circles yes I think
circles okay I'm ready and then we're
gonna do what like a three minute
challenge here something like that okay
so I think a big part of this is going
to be making sure the laptop stays level
yes because you know you TSA you got to
be moving someone behind you yelling at
you yeah
he's missing on his face
you're about to miss your flight okay
okay all right all right I'm ready to go
so I need a PowerPoint before you guys
go on vacation okay uh I know you're all
excited uh I need a PowerPoint on why I
am the greatest and okay I should not
have been kicked off my show okay okay I
can do that all right I'm downloading my
template oh geometric color block let's
go
got my laptop on the ground because I'm
trying to push this suitcase too hard
let's hope that doesn't happen so it's
gonna happen it's mine my 360 hinge
shows how durable everything is it's all
right we gotta keep moving oh my God
how many slides do we need uh I feel
like I need some charts maybe a graph no
you don't uh you know okay fine
something I could show to the investors
about why I'm better than Austin Evans
this is hard because they're really hard
these suitcases have big handles on them
I'm I'm sweating right now
it's I mean smart smart
this is this is very challenging for
Matt
fan of star wipes no I'm making a
transition quality performance I like to
have a little Pizzazz in my in my
presentations
[Music]
don't mind me this is just the way I
walk through the airport and you know
what I like to end my PowerPoints with
I'm not done yet I've got a lot more
inputs some Pizzazz so I want you to
find the cutest animal you can find and
put it in the Powerpoints
I gotta keep moving
[Music]
I get a lot of breath there yeah I'm
walking faster because my web page won't
load for some reason do you think do you
think walking faster will load the way
I'm never gonna be done with this this
is a really hard challenge this is hard
okay I think we quit okay all right
let's just turn in what we've got okay
I'm just gonna delete all of the ones
that I did not use now when you email
them to me I will have an out of office
until Monday why Matt deserves Glory at
presentation and dissertation by Austin
Evans don't mind the extra hand I
couldn't give her that that primary
goals Matt is better than Austin it's a
known fact it's a fact not a goal I need
I need to say that because I need to get
points look at the quarterly report uh
Pope pre-mat the numbers were very bad
and getting worse postmat they got
better every quarter wow we went from
0.3 to 88 with Matt and I maintained
apparently zero column one group called
on growth I couldn't delete we want that
to be zero there's no Freer post map
there's just Matt so that's my
dissertation got it
uh where's the animal uh
it's it's something I couldn't get
nothing so you okay Matt is the best
yeah five
I promise there's Transitions okay okay
why Matt is the best he's kind funny
handsome cool and likes things
uh four of those things are correct why
Matt is better than Austin that is just
a better person that's true it's fine
um Matt is art
I've seen that at MoMA yeah
cute animal
I never had a shot did I never had a
shot like I asked for something I expect
to get it and you just didn't deliver it
but look at your quarterly performance
where's your graph on my Matt's
performance is quarterly excellent did
ask for I did but I I mean uh
let me show you this oh
oh look at that transition wait wait oh
she does have to change
but I didn't see a star wipe to that
animal there was a star wipe somewhere
but not to the animal
that was a star right
yeah but at least there's an animal I
guess this is the last challenge so who
do you think won this challenge I think
you're gonna have to check out our video
over on this is and determine for
yourself because we went head to head
with all these competitions but who won
this one oh yeah no you okay yeah all
right
uh well this was actually really really
fun thank you guys so much for watching
and make sure you go check out their
Channel because the other half of this
video to see who wins will be there and
you'll be able to tally it up yourself
because we're not going to spoil it you
also go to the link in the description
and buy the VivoBook 16x the superior
laptop
S14 for the win yeah I wish mine was a
little too big for this challenge I'm
not gonna lie that would have been
better my fingers are smashed like
because I was holding it like this and
trying to like cruise around but when
they said they have an ergonomic
keyboard design I don't think they had
this particular challenge in mind this
one was a little outside but you find it
ergonomic though did a pretty good job I
mean I still managed to type I think
it's best when it's on a stationary
surface not your hand definitely it does
look very clean though
yeah no no bacteria anymore
what's your regards
and hit the Bell to be notified when we
post new videos see you later
[Music]